I'm a fan I'm a friend I think he's a I
think he's I think he's been I think
he's been uh sold a bill of goods we'll
see what happens here the latest news I
saw your episode that you did uh the
other day with the when we covered his
how-to traffic women guys so yeah this
whole lover boy method thing was where
you can make women fall in love with you
um which is not easy to do by the way
but you make women fall of June then you
coerce them into trafficking the charges
I guess against him now are
trafficking trafficking potentially
doubt that forming an eye organizing
crime group and then the easiest ones
well they'll always get you if they want
to get you are money laundering and tax
evasion that's how they get Capone
that's how they get all these guys okay
I guess the latest news is he's been
detained put additional 30 days
um in Romanian prison
um I really enjoyed that that thing that
breakdown you did with the Romanian
attorney basically breaking down the
case you did that and then snico came on
and I don't know kind of said his case
yeah what was that what snake I was
doing to entertain what was gonna go
doing slurping up oh wow all you guys do
you guys suck them off so hard no no
I've called out Tate on a few things all
right so there's people in the chat
they're like oh Adam said one bad thing
about Tate he should go to hell now it's
like relaxed dude
um but you interviewed Tate recently I
think you were the last interview of
Tate before you went to jail okay so I
want to get the panels uh
basically take on a what are your
thoughts on Tate do you think these
charges are trumped up do you think he's
actually going to be seeing real
legitimate jail time here and what will
the final outcome be so you want to go
first well I don't I don't know all the
facts of the case I'd like to say so I
from what I understand could you explain
more about like well let's let the man
who just want to break down I don't know
so Andrew Tate is being accused of
essentially he gets women
um into this like mind state where
they're very much into him and I think
his goal is to get that woman to a
dinner with another woman that works for
him he gets that woman to convince the
other woman that is like in love with
him to like start camming and doing sex
work and I think he flies him out too I
think they were doing their business in
Romania he basically has like this like
cam girl Sweatshop set up in their
basement where he's got all these women
working and then he just kind of like
keeps them strung along that way like
doing camming [ __ ] defrauding them on
their taxes and stealing money from them
uh and then doing that indefinitely and
then there's also some of of the charges
I think accused of threats of physical
and emotional abuse I think as well and
then there was that one threat of uh or
that was the right thing too but I don't
know if that was accused to Andrew if I
just said that was about the four people
so it might not have been Andrew himself
that was the case of that but the whole
thing is that
he said all of this on camera loudly and
proudly meaning here is my business
model
as case example you're a pretty girl you
want to make some money you're doing
only fans you're doing all types of
video chatting things anyway okay come
with me
and you can make ten thousand dollars no
it was one flaw he's going for New Girls
yeah okay all right so he's recruiting
you have you have existing sales people
and you have new sales people that's how
businesses work yeah I'm just I mean I'm
just blowing it down to the basics hear
me out hear me out before everyone jumps
in
you can make ten thousand dollars a
month in my business model but I keep
half
or you can attempt to do it yourself and
you can make two thousand dollars a
month and you can do it and you keep a
hundred percent
here are your options and that's the way
that he's broken it down on camera
multiple times so he says I've seen it
consistently go out and try to do it on
your own you make less money come to me
you'll make more but I'm also going to
make some money and that's how he made
his [ __ ] money and that's his
business model the video wasn't he was
doing tax evasion money laundering
coercion that's another story but he's
been very open up that's what the
business the business model he wasn't
selling it oh sorry you want to talk
about it no I just had a question about
so were the girls free to leave the
whole time
that that's I think a contentious point
I think there were logs leaked where
there was talk of passport holding and
that that's where the threat of physical
and emotional violence come in but I
would have to see what the actual
accusations and the accusations
um what did they accuse him of you said
human trade no it was um emotional you
said something so there were four people
that I don't know if there's been a new
press release but the Romanian document
announced four people
um undertaping one of them of those four
people one of them
um uh there was uh to create a criminal
organization there was uh sex
trafficking and then there was the money
laundering but I don't think it's
specifically who was charged with what
that's my memory here's what I'll say
and this this is totally my opinion
totally my opinion let's say Andrew Tate
had a hundred girls working for him
let's just say
and 99 of them
were free to leave all good do whatever
you want no issues whatsoever and then
there was this one girl who had [ __ ]
issues there was a she threw up in the
house and wouldn't clean it up I think
snico brought up this example yeah
that's right Andrew Tate's friend sneako
said whatever I'm just saying I'm giving
I I wasn't there I'm not I'm not here to
clean up the vomit no that's fine I'm
just saying I can see how this slippery
slope happens there's this one girl 99
of the other girls are fine they're
making the money whatever again this is
my opinion there's one girl
does something wrong throws up
disrespects talk [ __ ] whatever it was
and now there's an issue with this one
girl and they're gonna take this issue
with this one girl that he held her
passport or he wronged her or he
physically harassed her because this one
girl was acting up so now you want to
take this one case and paint this broad
brush around this dude that he's just
raping and pillaging women Galore and
that to me is I think unfair okay
I said that is my opinion sure if what
if he's doing what he said he did in his
videos he is a sex trafficker full stop
like what he says that he gets girls to
fall in love with them he says that he
brings them to a dinner with another
girl that's working for him with the
express intent of that girl to convince
this girl did she freely choose to do it
I just don't I'm sorry if I'm thinking
okay I'm putting myself in these girls
shoes I get a boyfriend right and the
boyfriend convinces me to do cam work
that was my decision that's great that
you think that's personal decisions
personal responsibilities
can you not cut me off like I'm just
tired of like we're gonna blame the men
for your poor decision you picked to do
it that's great that you feel the way
but it's still sex trafficking your
personal feelings don't matter that's
the way you're a European girl living in
the former USSR you have no other job
options and you're hot and you're young
about the money they weren't complaining
about the money but he was actively
stealing from them yeah
he literally said when you're filling
out these dumb women's tax forms you can
lie to them about the tax firm says take
20 40 off the top that is where I think
you were right yeah that is where I
think you were right hear me out that is
where I think they will get him yeah
because even hold on even anything
discovered that point even if they will
in the church all the time it's still
sex trafficking if I fly to another
country bring you to a country you don't
speak the language like you to basement
I'm gonna tell you like hey stream it
I'll cut you out of this sex trafficking
for me that's
definition wise maybe you're right okay
I don't know that's great to me is not
sex trafficking that's fine because I
agree with pearl these women knew what
they were doing they knew what they were
signing up for they were free to leave
he wasn't holding their passports but if
he was skimming money off the top with
taxes yeah that's what they'll get so
this is these are the two stages and I
agree that that's what you're gonna say
because I know that's what all the tape
fans are going to say first they're
going to say he didn't do it and then
when they said he did do it and it's
obviously clearly sex trafficking then
it's gonna be oh okay well sure he's
secretary but it's okay that's not even
like real sex Trevor who cares about sex
trafficking they chose to go to another
country where they didn't speak the
language he was stealing money from them
and they were locked in for the first
time ever during sex I have a question
so I don't know anything about the
Romanian legal system I don't I don't
know the definition of that okay I'm not
going to pretend you don't have a uh I'm
sorry
I don't I don't know I don't study sex
trafficking okay it's not my area of
expertise but my question is what is
incorrect about that statement do you
not think the women should take
accountability for the choices that they
made they should but that's besides the
point you can take it kind of I'm not
asking about what the punishment should
be for the women they probably punish
enough I imagine they've worked and had
money stolen from them what we're
talking about was what Andrew Tate did
which is sex trafficking right they're
probably going to make bad decisions
they really chose to do it why is it
wrong if I get somebody in a
relationship with me and then I'm able
to flip that into them working as a
prostitute for me you freely chose to do
it I just think there's
an eagle guy that could make me want to
do that that's great for you but this
isn't about you the story isn't about
you I love how passionate you are and
the words you use but we have to be
careful these aren't prostitutes they
are they hear me out sex workers they're
on camera doing cam girl [ __ ] at any
point they can turn off their camera at
any point they can say I don't feel like
it today but they're doing it to make
money this is a job so they can make
money now only fans they're in another
country where they don't speak the
language and speak the languages anybody
at any time could go and buy and sell
the right options the right puts their
calls to be a billionaire that's true
but the hard part is making the picks
right if you're flown to a whole other
[ __ ] country you've got some dude
that you think is your [ __ ] boyfriend
that's in love with you and now you're
doing sex work the first time in your
[ __ ] life you don't speak the
language around here the guy's stealing
money from you who knows people that
know how to I'm sorry unless these girls
are beyond naive if they see 99 other
girls there okay cool they don't think
this is my boyfriend and he loves it
that's great and he's like now I'm a
part of a harem there's literally a name
for the Memories called the lover boy
method this is exactly what they do but
if you don't care about sex driving
that's fine and a lot of people
which is cool I'm not saying I don't
care about sex trafficking would you say
that there's the Jeffrey Epstein sex
trafficking and then there's the Tate
thing and they're not even [ __ ] close
yeah sure right yeah what date your kids
what's the definition of sex trafficking
I don't I I just where's Natalia because
I would just think that it was that you
weren't free to go that's what I thought
I thought it's only sex trafficking if
the trafficking if they're underage or
they can't leave that's what I thought
no you said there's three things I
believe there is I watched some legal
breakdown there's there's got to be
physical pressure physical violence
coercion and one more
um yeah yeah
we don't really know about because we
don't know what the evidence because
that's all he that's all he says she
said right now right now but we don't
know what evidence the police has that's
that's what it comes down to yeah I
think the only reasonable position is to
be agnostic until you see what develops
of the case yeah here's I think here's I
think the biggest Point here
Tate has become famous for talking that
[ __ ] on social media on YouTube on tick
tock on Instagram
and what you know what will make you
famous will also [ __ ] you might will
[ __ ] put your ass in jail and that's
the problem that he's having right now I
do this is I'll make my money I'm a
badass it's like yo this guy's sick let
me follow this guy uh you're going to
jail for the exact same reason that's
the problem go to jail for yeah what are
you talking he's such [ __ ] he said
he's going to jail because he's in an
Eastern European country that wants to
[ __ ] be taken serious on the world
stage and he's bragging about sex
trafficking in the [ __ ] country
that's why he got charges
but Andrew Tate isn't known for telling
young men how to sex traffic he's known
for challenging The Matrix and
challenging the systems
about that he might have been talking
about it but that's not why he gained
population that's not why people are
saying he's being targeted by Romania or
the Western World people are saying oh
they're targeting him because he's
telling young men
thinking is the fact that he's bragged
about so much publicly so many times if
you want to know what I think Tate
stands for what actually think he stands
for it's not okay he talks about the
Matrix in the system and he has very
loudly talked about how he makes his
money and the cam girls and he talks
about you know whether he's toxic
masculinity what he's labeled as what I
actually think Tate stands for is just
male self-improvement getting in the gym
going being a badass making money and if
you make the money you get the women you
get the Bugattis but he's talking about
becoming a better version of yourself
but nobody wants to talk about that they
want to talk about being a sex
trafficker they want to talk about him
doing all the [ __ ] ridiculous things
out there that to me is his message but
it gets masked by all this other
nonsense so here's my next question to
you let's say Tate is innocent let's
just say Tate is innocent go with me
here who do you think is pulling the
strings trying to get him [ __ ] set up
and put in jail go with me here who do
you think is do you think it's
corporations you think it's government
for sure I think it's Greta thundberg
you think it's the world economic Forum
you think it's the US government you
think it's like let's just say Tate's
innocent and he hasn't done any of this
but and it's until proven guilty ladies
and gentlemen who do you think is saying
this [ __ ] Tate guy we got to bring
this [ __ ] down I don't think
there needs to be I don't think there
needs to be a big conspiracy I think can
be as simple as either a prosecutor
doesn't like him and makes the wrong
decision sometimes police mess up or it
could be the U.S embassy put a little
pressure on Romania that could have also
happened but I don't think there's this
big International conspiracy so you
don't think it says it goes to some top
World economic Forum Charles Schwab
Charles Schwab Chuck Schwab I've heard
that name so much World economic foreign
official who's like our country is
trying to be taken more seriously okay
Eastern European countries are like I
think vying for validity from the west
and now we've got a guy that's in our
country you know flagrantly talking
about it bragging about [ __ ] sex
trafficking so we're gonna [ __ ] take
this guy down if if I was to entertain a
conspiracy that would be my guess I
would say this is that he talks about
corruption right and he goes every
company she's corrupt every company
she's corrupt now do you want to be in a
country like the West because tatus
talks very badly about the United States
the West UK London EU doesn't speak
highly above it that's why he likes more
Eastern Europe Dubai you know he's
converted to Islam uh he talks about the
fact that in Romania he's like I like
the fact that I could just go give a bag
of cash and get out of the corruption
and just pay it off well it hasn't
worked this time well that well that's
exactly and that's why I think that he
talks about the sex trafficking I think
that there's some prosecutor in Romania
like if you want to go there there's
some prosecutor in Romania or some judge
or some
you know legal Aristocrat whoever that's
like all right okay bro well test me
you're in my country let's see if we're
that corrupt and I think there's maybe
somebody with a bone to pick but so
maybe it's not the Charles Schwabs of
the world and the Greta Thunderbirds of
the world and the you know the Matrix
maybe it's just some dude in Rome really
too is it like when you talk about
corruption there's gonna be different
types of corruption right it wouldn't
surprise me if I could go to a place
like Romania and get like a speeding
ticket and pay off the cop maybe more
than I could in the United States but
like double homicide that's probably a
different thing so the idea that like
all corruption is the same and you think
of anybody for anything probably not
sure I think that's a very good example
if you're in Romania and you are doing
anything involved with casinos you're uh
what is it greasing wheels or Greece and
gears with like pretty bad people like
that's just like a gift you're
affiliated with that yeah absolutely
that has to be the case yeah but I don't
think that means you could get away with
like blatantly sex trafficking or like
raping or killing or like doing crazy
[ __ ] especially if you're not a high
profile figure if you are a horrified
profile figure yeah
all right so give me your uh your
prediction what's gonna happen to Tate
in 30 days prediction
me first yeah I I like to wait till the
facts of the case are out it could go
either way it could be that how
diplomatic of you well because it could
be that a couple women gave testimony
they can't um validate it anywhere else
they've got maybe a couple whatever text
messages and that's it um and then
nothing comes of it uh it could be that
he didn't do anything actually that
wrong maybe they'd all freely choose to
go there they thought they could make
some money they weren't happy with the
money they made and now they came back
and tried to burn them it could be that
he actually did engage in a whole bunch
of [ __ ] up [ __ ] and we're gonna see
way more release from the Romanian
authorities but it could be anything how
about this I'm going to re-ask the
question because forget about
predictions who knows what's gonna
happen because it's very easy to say
let's just wait for the case comes out
how about this let's just keep it simple
do you think that Tate who has taken the
Internet by storm over the last 6-12 as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on
on platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible